d'abord Steve les chiffres avec vous
pour qu'on comprenne bien de quoi parle
plusieurs millions de Français vivent
effectivement dans des déserts dans un
désert médical si ça huit millions de
Français seraient dans ce cas 63% des
Français auraient déjà renoncé au
reporté des soins en raison de délai
d'attendre trop long ou de distance trop
importante à parcourir plus de 5
millions de Français n'ont pas de
médecins traitant pour bien comprendre
l'urgence de la situation le mieux c'est
de se pencher sur une carte la pénurie
de mes seins elle concerne plusieurs
types de médecins notamment les
spécialistes ophtalmo gynéco pédiates
mais elles concerne aussi les
généralistes on va voir cette carte elle
a été publiée par l'association
UFC Que Choisir un Français sur quatre
n'a aujourd'hui pas accès à un médecin
généraliste il faut pour ces Français
faire plus de 30 minutes de route pour
obtenir une consultation on le voit sur
la carte toute la France est concernée
par le problème le Sud-Ouest est
relativement
épargner votre Charente notamment je
crois la Corse est très affecté Oriane
et puis en Mayenne ça va mal également
le département est le troisième désert
médical de France pour lutter contre ces
déserts la grande mesure adoptée par le
gouvernement c'est la loi de 2019 qui
surprime le numéro exclusus le numerus
clausus c'est ce dispositif qui fixait à
l'échelle nationale le nombre
d'étudiants admis en deuxième année de
médecine désormais c'est fini mais il va
falloir encore patienter de longues
années avant que le nombre de médecins
n'augmente réellement sur le terrain
merci Steve pour les chiffres la
situation est difficile on le voit elle
va empirer encore selon vous
guillaume-garo c'est pas moi qui le dis
ce sont tout simplement les chiffres du
ministère de la Santé lui-même puisque
on sait que le creux de la démographie
médicale il est devant nous il est à
l'horizon 2030 ça veut dire que plus ça
va aller moins ça va aller sauf si on
est capable de prendre des mesures
fortes et efficaces bien évidemment pour
que les inégalités entre les territoires
et donc entre les Français cessent de
s'aggraver comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et on va parler de ces
mesures il y a une fracture territoriale
sur ce sujet Corinne Imbert pour vous
bien sûr qu'il y a une fracture
territoriale et il y a même une fracture
territoriale soulignez que la
Charente-Maritime était plus tôt bien
dotée mais en fait quand on regarde et
qu'on fait un focus sur le département
ou bien évidemment on se rend compte
qu'il y a des zones plus en difficulté
que que d'autres notamment le plus
rurales les zones plus rurales le le
l'est du département le sud du
département donc il y a évidemment la
question de la démographie médicale et
là on sait qu'on va dans le mur c'est
pour ça qu'il était important de former
plus de médecins mais ça demande du
temps c'est un merveilleux métier mais
ça demande du temps et puis il y a la
question du temps médical il y a deux
choses parce que
plus de médecins ne veut pas dire plus
de temps médical c'est une profession
libérale chacun l'exerce comme il le
souhaite libéral ou salarié s'il le
souhaite mais quand on a un exercice
libéral on peut se dire aussi qu'il y a
une responsabilité qui incombe à cette
liberté mais il y a aussi un
et puis la notion de médical est
évidemment le temps médical est impacté
par les contraintes qu'on demande en
termes administratives aux médecins et
on va les venir parce que c'est un vrai
sujet sur la fracture territoriale
de répartition aussi on voyait à
l'instant à l'écran la carte qui a été
publié récemment par Que Choisir il faut
regarder aussi le négatif c'est-à-dire
où est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de médecins
et où est-ce qu'il y en a peu et les
chiffres là encore du ministère de la
Santé ils sont assez parlants vous savez
il y a trois fois plus de de généraliste
dans les Hautes-Alpes que dans
l'Eure-et-Loir 3 fois plus là c'est
uniquement la médecine générale mais si
on regarde les spécialités les autres
spécialités chez les dermatos il y a 17
fois plus de dermato par habitant dans à
Paris que dans l'Ariège et si on regarde
les ophtalmo vous portez des lunettes il
y en a 18 fois plus à Paris que dans la
Creuse toujours par habitant la densité
par habitant donc c'est à cette
inégalité là qu'il faut s'attaquer à
cette répartition là et donc c'est
là-dessus que nous faisons des
propositions moi vous savez Jeannine un
groupe de travail transpartisan à
l'Assemblée nationale pour essayer de
proposer
au législateur ça veut dire à la fois
aux députés comme au sénateur des
solutions qui soient rapides parce que
on peut pas attendre vous le disiez à
l'instant on peut pas attendre encore
des années qui est une nouvelle cote de
médecins formés il faut 10 ans il faut
le rappeler il faut 10 ans pour former
un médecin or c'est maintenant que les
problèmes se posent et on le rappelait
c'est maintenant que la situation
s'aggrave et c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit
le gouvernement que les mesures qu'ils
ont prises au début du précédent
quinquennat notamment sur le numerus
clausus et bien feront effet en 2027
2028 et encore si on a la capacité à
accueillir davantage
d'étudiants mais vous savez il y a ce
qui a été
[Musique]
sur la question des étudiants puisqu'on
va parler de cette cette 4e année
Corinne Imbert ce que disait
guillaume-garo c'est que on a beau
libérer le numérique clausus il faut
qu'il les gens derrière évidemment on
n'a pas pour autant construit des
nouvelles facultés de médecine pousser
les murs etc donc il y avait des
capacités d'accueil pour accueillir les
étudiants dans de bonnes conditions qui
n'ont pas changé entre le moment où
avant la loi et après le vote de la loi
donc quelque part c'était un petit peu à
l'heure alors on va nous dire qu'il y a
un petit peu plus d'étudiants en
médecine d'inscrit mais la réalité elle
est pas la hauteur des besoins des
attentes des Français on va faire réagir
justement un étudiant je vous fais
intervenir un peu plus tôt que prévu
Raphaël Prenot bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous interne en médecine
générale à Nantes président de l'Inter
syndicale national autonome
représentative des internes de médecine
générale on va parler de la quatrième
année mais une réaction peut-être sur ce
que vous venez d'entendre à l'instant
il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on partage
notamment sur le sur le constat mais
par contre il y a un point sur lequel on
n'est pas forcément d'accord quand on
nous dit que le problème principal c'est
un problème de répartition notamment sur
les médecins généralistes on est on est
pas vraiment d'accord aujourd'hui vous
avez montré des chiffres qui montrent
que effectivement on a perdu 5000
médecins généralistes depuis 10 ans que
on est sur une perspective de perdre 20%
environ de médecins généralistes et
d'effectif de médecins généralistes
aujourd'hui on a les chiffres de la CNAM
qui montre que les médecins généralistes
sont les professionnels de santé les
mieux répartis sur le territoire
le problème aujourd'hui c'est un
problème d'effectif ce qui va nous
permettre demain d'avoir de des médecins
traitants pour le plus grand nombre de
nos concitoyens c'est de garantir une
formation pleine des jeunes médecins
généralistes et les mesures qui sont
actuellement discutées au Parlement ça
va juste perdre en attractivité pour la
médecine générale et donc perdre des
futurs médecins généralistes à avoir
pour nos pour nos concitoyens dans les
prochaines années
sur l'alerte c'est une forme d'alerte
qu'on vient de faire Raphaël prénom oui
je comprends vu de sa place c'est normal
et d'un autre côté vous avez des élus
qui est mon collègue René Paul savarylle
il l'a dit tout à l'heure il est parti
il a parlé de coups de semence hier soir
au Sénat alors je rassure Raphaël les
mesures coercitives qui étaient
proposées par voie d'amendement hier
dans la discussion du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale non
pas été votée à titre personnel je pense
que ce n'est pas une bonne mesure on va
répartir un nombre de médecins qui n'est
pas assez important je dis pas qu'il y a
pas un sujet mais je dis que de toute
façon ça sera contre-productif et je
partage et je partage qui vient d'être
dit parce que le risque c'est quoi c'est
soit on va faire que la médecine
générale sera encore moins attractive
soit en réparti en la pénurie ou en
mettant de la coercition au
conventionnement et bien les médecins
qui voudront s'installer à tel endroit
passeront en secteur 2
auront des honoraires un peu plus
importants et travailleront peut-être
moins c'est ça aussi et on créera même
si la médecine est déjà un petit pas de
vitesse on créera encore un écart et des
difficultés pour l'axe aux messages
généralistes
je voudrais répondre à ce qui vient
d'être dit on dit ah il y a un problème
d'attractivité
du métier de médecin généraliste ce qui
est vrai c'est que on n'a pas moins de
médecins depuis 10 ans on a un peu moins
de généraliste et un peu plus de
spécialistes
et sur l'attractivité du métier de
médecin faut redire les choses vous
savez il y a 400 000 vœux de lycéens en
2020 pour rentrer dans la carrière
médicale et plus généralement dans les
professions de santé 400 000 il y en a
combien qui sont acceptés en première
année
35000 il y a combien qui passeront la
deuxième année 10000 ça veut dire que
l'attractivité elle est là simplement il
y a une sélection extrêmement forte et
tant mieux qu'on soit exigeant mais il y
a plein de jeunes en France plein de
jeunes qui veulent devenir médecin
simplement il faut peut-être qu'on
interroge aussi la qualité de ses études
de médecine et la sélection parce qu'on
a vu beaucoup de gens qui étaient cassés
à l'issue de la première année à travers
des épreuves de sélection qui était on
va dire parfois étonnante dans leur
critères bon je n'en dis pas plus mais
simplement il faut réfléchir aussi à ce
que sont aujourd'hui les études de nos
médecins
j'entends notamment dire que on a
énormément de demandes par les lycéens
le problème de l'attractivité il se pose
aussi au sein de nos études la médecine
générale pour les pour les étudiants qui
finissent leur sixième année elles ne
remplissait pas depuis deux ans donc il
y a vraiment un vrai sujet sur le fait
de la rendre attractive et que ce soit
les mesures coercitives ou même les
propositions de quatrième année comme
porte madame Imbert aussi c'est vraiment
dramatique pour pour la suite pour la
rétractivité notre spécialité et aussi
vis-à-vis de l'abandon dans nos études
il faut aussi se rendre compte que il y
a plus de 10% de des gens qui passent le
concours de qui arrivent en deuxième
année qui vont abandonner leurs études
médicales au cours du cursus parce que
nos études médicales elles sont
maltraitantes parce que nous études
médicales elles mettent à mal nos
étudiants et que demain on va avoir des
vrais soucis si on continue de la sorte
et la quatrième année telle que la
propose aujourd'hui ce sera une année
maltraitance de plus pour nos étudiants
un mot sur cette ce mot qui est fort
maltraitant c'est après on va parler de
cette quatrième année le Conseil des
Sévères de la part de Raphaël Fresno
mais mais il est juste sans doute et les
témoignages ils sont très nombreux dans
ce sens-là ce que je veux dire
néanmoins c'est qu'il faut bien qu'on
trouve des solutions maintenant parce
que on peut être contre tout on peut
être contre la quatrième année
d'internat on peut être contre des
mesures de régulation en disant non non
c'est pas un problème de répartition
mais on fait quoi on fait quoi pour les
patients qui sont sans médecin vous
l'avez rappelé c'est quand même 6
millions de Français sont pas de
médecins traitant 8 millions de Français
qui ont un problème d'accès aux soins et
si on en croit que choisir 15 millions
de Français qui sont dans une grande
difficulté tout simplement pour accéder
à la santé donc vraiment il faut traiter
le problème et pas dire c'est la faute
des autres il faut qu'ensemble on trouve
des solutions et moi je vous ferai des
propositions on peut plus tard dans
notre bas là dessus autour de la
régulation de l'installation pour nos
médecins comme ça existe pour d'autres
professionnels de de santé même si c'est
vrai il y a pas une seule solution et on
va en parler et l'une des mesures c'est
cette quatrième année des précisions
style oui alors le Sénat beaucoup bossé
un tout sur tous ces problèmes de désert
médicaux pas moins de 6 rapports
parlementaires ont été remis sur la
question durant le précédent quinquennat
ce travail a notamment débouchés sur une
loi qui a été adoptée par le scénar le
18 octobre dernier le texte était
proposé par le patron du groupe LR Bruno
retaillod et cet ex vise à mettre en
place une quatrième année d'internat en
médecine générale contre trois
actuellement cette quatrième année sera
réalisée exclusivement en ambulatoire
c'est à dire pas à l'hôpital en médecine
de ville réalisée de préférence dans les
territoires les moins pourvus en
médecins généralistes donner des idées
donc au gouvernement puisqu’un
dispositif Imposs similaire a été inséré
dans le budget de la Sécu les sénateurs
tenaient à leur propre version et c'est
donc cette version qui a été adoptée
hier par le Sénat expliquez-nous quand
on est pas spécialiste à différence
entre la version du gouvernement et la
version adoptée par les sénateurs hier
la version de adoptée hier c'est la
version de la proposition de loi de
brûlure Retailleau est un certain nombre
de mes collègues adopter il y a trois
semaines au Sénat on a remis on a
réécrit l'article dans dans les mêmes
termes puisqu'elle dit cette ce que dit
cet article en l'état c'est que cette
quatrième année de professionnalisation
parle bien de l'année
professionnalisation et il y a eu des
concertations il y a eu une écoute des
internes il y a déjà un peu plus d'un an
selon le ministre et Bruno Retailleau
avant d'écrire la proposition de loi
avaient reçu les internes également dans
son département pour évoquer ce sujet
avec eux c'est qu'elle soit réalisée au
plus près des territoires et en priorité
en priorité dans les zones où en zone
Soudan c'est à dire que là où il y a pas
assez de médecins généralistes elle dit
aussi qu'il y aura une reconnaissance
parce que cette quatrième année les
jeunes internes le font sous le statut
de docteur junior
il s'agit et vous attendiez cette
quatrième année de professionnalisation
il y a 4 ans cette proposition loi ce
texte il est voté il s'appliquera aux
internes messagères en ouvrant 2026 donc
il y a 4 ans pour former encore plus de
messages généralistes pour qu'il soit
médecin pour ceux qui sont déjà dans un
interlocuteurs en internat c'est ce
qu'elle dit moi il y a quelque chose que
je comprends pas très bien dans les
arguments qui nous sont opposés on dit
il ne faut pas une quatrième année
d'internat sous-entendu la troisième
année d'internat suffit et donc on
serait prêt nous à s'installer en
médecine libérale tout de suite au soir
de la troisième année et puis là on nous
dit ah mais non parce que finalement la
quatrième année on n'est pas encore
assez formé donc on veut des maîtres de
stage donc on peut pas être sur les les
deux tableaux il faut choisir soit on
est prêt au bout de la troisième année
et on s'oppose à la quatrième année
d'internat soit on accepte la quatrième
anathénée d'internat et on reconnaît que
on a déjà des compétences donc voilà il
faut il faut choisir et puis il faut pas
vouloir courir de lièvres à la fois je
pense qu'il faut surtout de la cohérence
si vous avez besoin de formation si vous
avez besoin de formation vous avez donc
besoin d'une quatrième année
on n'a pas montré la quatrième année ce
qui veut dire que la troisième année
n'était pas suffisante
de formation sauf qu'on n'a pas de
formateur à appliquer aux gens et il
faut arrêter de dire que un médecin qui
sort de cursus il doit être prêt dès le
lendemain à être installé forcément on a
aussi besoin des remplaçants qu'est-ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui
ils ne peuvent pas prendre de vacances
les remplaçants ils sont nécessaires
aussi au système de santé et il faut pas
l'oublier mais un remplaçant ça veut
dire donc dire qu'il est en capacité
d'exercer la médecine quand bien même il
est remplaçant
oui mais vous le verrez vous le verrez
les remplaçants donc les remplaçants ils
ne veulent pas exercer seul les
remplaçants quand ils remplacent ils
cherchent des cabinets de groupe ils ont
des médecins à côté de ça qu'il faut
travailler c'est peut-être ça qu'il faut
travailler
il n'y aura plus parce que là on est sur
un débat on est sur un débat très
technique et ça va peut-être ce que je
veux dire va peut-être dans le sens de
Raphaël quand on regarde les chiffres
c'est vrai que il y a un interne qui se
suicide aujourd'hui vu que les trois
semaines il y a un problème général
c'est ça a été c'est des chiffres qui
ont été notamment cités dans
l'hémicycléaire par la gauche du Sénat
donc c'est quand même assez préoccupant
est-ce que donc déjà j'imagine que ça
vous préoccupe aussi mais est-ce que il
y a pas insister un problème plus
général on fait peser tous les problèmes
du système de santé sur les internes
aujourd'hui avec cette quatrième année
qu'on rajoute en médecine générale mais
nous sommes absolument d'accord d'abord
pour reconnaître que c'est dur d'être
interne aujourd'hui et il faut remercier
je le fais publiquement les internes de
tenir à bout de bras nos hôpitaux ça
vraiment il faut le dire et sans doute
et moi je vais dans le sens de Ravel
predo qu'il faut mieux rémunérer les
internes lorsqu'il assure ses tâches à
l'hôpital est-ce que pour autant tout
doit être assumé toute la solution
relève des internes à l'évidence non
c'est la raison pour laquelle et j'y
reviens quand même excusez-moi je pense
qu'il faut de la régulation dans
l'installation la question
d'installation des médecins dont on
parle beaucoup
est-ce que je vous ai dit ça non alors
vous allez juste m'écouter la régulation
c'est d'abord dire de ne plus autoriser
l'installation de médecins dans les
zones qui sont déjà suffisamment dotés
vous allez on n'a pas montré la carte
mais vous allez dans des villes côtières
dans des villes du littoral du sud de la
France ça va très bien c'est les 15%
dont vous parliez première chose on
arrête d'aggraver les inégalités et deux
en effet pour les nouvelles
installations mais ça ne concerne pas
simplement les jeunes médecins on dit
vous vous installer où vous voulez mais
dans un dans une zone qui est
aujourd'hui en désertification médicale
c'est comme ça étape et ça permet à mon
sens de répondre à la demande des
patients et ça doit concerner je termine
juste là-dessus autant les généralistes
que les spécialistes je citer tous les
dermato les ophtalmo je pense que c'est
l'ensemble des spécialités qui doit être
concerné par ces mesures il va falloir
qu'on avancer l'optimisation médicale
c'est ce qui va nous permettre demain
d'avoir du efficacité ce sera pas la
régulation on nous met trop souvent en
position de dire qu'on ne propose pas de
solution ce n'est pas le cas on a même
fait un coloc à destination tous les
parlementaires au début du mois
d'octobre vous n'êtes pas déplacé on
porte des solutions qui sont fortes qui
sont des propositions d'optimisation du
temps médical de réduction de la charge
administrative de permettre
l'embauche d'assistant médicaux et
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas mises en
place
dans dans ce débat très rapidement
Corine Imbert parce qu'il faut qu'on
parle des des médecins retraités juste
le texte de la proposition ne dis pas
que cette quatrième année se fera là où
il y a pas d'autres médecins
elle ne dit pas cela elle ne dit pas ça
elle ne dit pas que l'interne ira là
exercer tout seul dans son cabinet
médical dans un cabinet médical ne
faites pas dire à cette proposition de
loi ce qu'elle ne dit pas on va parler
des médecins retraités parce que il faut
qu'on avance dans le débat c'est une
autre mesure inciter les médecins
retraités à rester en activité on vous
emmène à Maubeuge c'est Audrey vitaz qui
a suivi un médecin généraliste en emploi
retraite voir ce qu'il en pense
aurait pu s'arrêter de travailler en
avril dernier il avait toutes ses
annuités mais à 66 ans ce médecin
généraliste de Maubeuge a fait le choix
de continuer en cumulent emploi retraite
la ville est en carence de médecin alors
pour ses patients c'est un soulagement
non
si le docteur coquet continue c'est
qu'il a participé entre autres à la
création de cette maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire où il travaille en
coordination avec une infirmière et une
secrétaire le dossier est alimenté
l'infirmière elle elle vérifie par
exemple sur un dossier de patient
chronique lu sa dernière prise de sang
son dernier bilan cardio j'ai plus
besoin de faire toute cette ce travail
qui n'est pas un travail administratif
mais très chronophage si je ne travaille
pas avec une infirmière et que je sais
pas qui a quelqu'un le matin et que je
travaille pas en équipe j'aurais arrêté
j'aurais arrêté à 65 ans et 6 mois il
faut que j'arrive à passer tout ça à
passer les flambeaux et que je ne suis
pas pressé parce que au stade où je
travaille après 37 ans de carrière quand
je reçois des patients
je ne sais pas si c'est un vrai travail
mais les cotisations vieillesse qu'il
paye elle sont bien réelles comme tous
les médecins libéraux entre 10000 et
30000 euros chaque année même si il est
déjà à la retraite ce sont ces
cotisations qu'Emmanuel Macron veut
supprimer pour inciter les médecins qui
exercent dans des déserts médicaux à
continuer alors j'y suis évidemment
favorable cela dit il y a toujours le
bon côté et le mauvais côté premièrement
quand vous regardez le texte il dit que
ça va quand même dépendre du chiffre
d'affaires or si un médecin retraité
continue son activité je suis pas sûr
qu'il ait envie de diminuer son chiffre
d'affaires de façon drastique ou non
intelligent c'est à dire que moi si je
suis ici c'est pour répondre à une
demande d'autre part c'est bien gentil
de dire on va plus cotiser mais je crois
qu'on est à peu près 12000 mètres
de retraite qui s'appelle la carpe et 12
mm qui cotiseraient plus ça un gros trou
dans le budget pour le papy boom d'après
lui il faudrait aussi permettre le
salariat des médecins retraités à
Maubeuge ce n'est toujours pas possible
il a l'air aussi sur la situation des
infirmières libérales qui elles payent
toujours des cotisations vieillesse
d'autant plus que la retraite de base
d'une infirmière est vraiment
aura des pâquerettes donc s'il pouvait
nous éviter de payer de la caisse de
retraite et le pont en profiter puisque
finalement on en profitera pas c'est
c'est du vent ce serait franchement
sympa pour nous du côté de la ville on
se satisfait de ces retraités qui
continuent même si tout le monde le
concède ce n'est pas une solution
d'avenir très sincèrement je pense que
c'est un pansement ni plus ni moins je
pense qu'il faut attirer les jeux de
médecins sur notre territoire nous avons
d'ailleurs comme projet à la ville de
Maubeuge de faire venir au printemps
2023 avec le partenariat de l'Université
de Lille l'UFR 3S 300 étudiants sur
notre territoire avec l'espoir d'attirer
de futurs médecins généralistes pour les
30 000 habitants de la commune
on va parler du salariat des médecins
traités c'est une proposition mais un
mot puisque le Sénat a donné son feu
vert à l'extension de cette allègement
des cotisations non plus seulement
médecin mais à l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé c'est quelque
chose que vous allez suivre à
l'Assemblée on verra on aura la
discussion dans l'hémicycle avec avec
les groupes tout ce qui peut permettre
des solutions dans l'urgence bien sûr
faisons-le mais j'observe juste une
chose on nous dit ah il faut travailler
plus longtemps c'est le projet de
réforme des retraites du gouvernant pour
dire parce que il y a besoin de
renflouer les caisses de de notre régime
de retraite et puis là paf surgit une
forme de de bonus pour les médecins et
les professionnels de santé qui eux
n'auraient pas à cotisé plus longtemps
donc il y a une forme de paradoxe ou de
contradiction là dedans mais je le redis
ce qui compte véritablement c'est qu'on
trouve des solutions il y a pas une
seule solution il y a un ensemble de
solutions et celle là en fait
en effet que des médecins retraités
puissent continuer à travailler plus
longtemps c'est ce cumul emploi retraite
très bien mais on l'a été ça a été dit
dans le reportage c'est pas non plus la
solution et on est bien d'accord
là-dessus bien sûr qu'il faudra former
davantage de nouveaux médecins on l'a
dit tout à l'heure on y revient pas
ensuite moi je crois qu'il faut être sur
la régulation dans l'installation et
l'exercice ça veut dire ne plus
autoriser une installation dans une zone
qui est déjà bien pourvue en présence
médicale mais pour ça il faut définir
des indicateurs pour dire ce qu'est une
zone bien pourvue et c'est qu'est une
zone mal pour vous il y a beaucoup de
cartes qui circulent mais il faut qu'il
y ait un indicateur public et
transparent c'est la première chose et
puis deux il faut que dans dans le
moment très compliqué où nous sommes je
vous parlais des 8 prochaines années
d'ici 2030 hier en effet des mesures
fortes vigoureuses qui soient
transitoire bien évidemment mais on dit
voilà pour les prochaines installations
il faudra que ce soit dans une zone sous
dotée ça concerne les jeunes médecins
mais ça concerne ça pourrait concerner
tout tout les médecins alors appelons ça
comme vous voulez enfin c'est une
contrainte assez
à mon avis qui n'est pas un surmontable
puisque on est dans une grande partie
vous l'avez montré sur la carte du
territoire national et je vais vous dire
c'est une question d'intérêt général
parce que c'est normal que les internes
s'expriment c'est normal que les
syndicats de médecins défendent aussi
leurs intérêts mais notre rôle à nous
responsable politique législateur c'est
défendre l'intérêt général c'est
défendre les patients c'est défendre
l'accès de tous à la santé à la médecine
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut trouver
ensemble je dis bien ensemble avec les
médecins et l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé des solutions
qui soient efficaces qui soient
urgente et rapide donc de telle sorte
que tout le monde puisse avoir un
médecin près de chez soi et la réponse
pour conclure il nous reste 45 secondes
[Rires]
et il y a d'autant plus urgences qu'on
parle beaucoup des
professionnels de santé qui aujourd'hui
travaillent prennent cher chaque jour
des patients nous sommes deux ans et
demi après le début de la pandémie tous
ces professionnels là médecins et autres
infirmiers pharmaciens sage-femme etc
sont en train de s'épuiser parce que
vous avez on parle beaucoup du temps
médical on parle beaucoup des futurs
médecins on oublie un petit peu ceux qui
sont sur le terrain aujourd'hui à la
ville comme à l'hôpital si l'hôpital va
pas bien la ville n'ira pas bien mais si
la ville ne va pas bien de l'eau
piétonne n'aura pas bien donc oui
urgence parce que sinon notre système de
santé va nous éclater à la figure et ce
sera le mot de la fin il y aura encore
beaucoup de choses à dire on refera un
débat sur sur ce sujet si vous êtes
d'accord parce qu'effectivement c'est un
vaste sujet d'inquiétude
[Musique]